PRESENTER: Hi.
Today we're going to
see how Document AI can
help unlock insights
from documents
with machine learning.
Data is crucial in
helping businesses
make smart decisions.
But today, much of that
valuable information
is dark data, stored in formats
that are difficult to analyze,
as handwritten forms,
PDFs, images, and emails.
Companies in all
industries and sizes,
from financial institutions
to media companies
to medical organizations,
face this challenge.
That's where Document AI,
Google Cloud's solution
for understanding documents
like forms, IDs, and invoices
can help.
Here's an example of what a
solution built with Document AI
might look like.
Acme, a fictional dental
insurance company,
processes thousands
of claims each week.
Previously, when
they received a form
from a dentist's
office or a patient,
an Acme employee would
manually enter all of the claim
information into a database.
This was tedious,
time consuming,
and lengthened the
claim's processing time.
Thanks to Document AI, Acme
has automated the process
and reduced the average
time to close a claim.
Now when a new
claim is received,
the form is uploaded to the
Acme dental claim portal.
Next, the Document AI API
analyzes the claim and extracts
data from its fields,
like patient information,
procedure details, and
dentist authorization.
After data is extracted
from the claim,
the Acme dental claim
portal automatically
stores it in a
BigQuery database.
Acme can easily search,
browse, and analyze claim data,
allowing them to make
better business decisions.
So how did Acme do it?
When a claim is uploaded, it's
sent to the Document AI API.
This API uses a
specialized model
to understand form fields,
tables, and check boxes.
Once data is extracted
from the application,
it's stored in BigQuery,
Google Cloud's data warehouse,
where it can be queried,
allowing Acme to service
insights through their portal.
Now Acme employees
can store claims
in a database, flag anomalies,
and make better business
decisions, faster, without the
burden of manual data input.
To learn more about how Document
AI can help you gain insights
from your documents,
check out the Document AI
page on Cloud.Google.com,
and thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]